welcome to this video playing dokie
that's John none played him before I
have a piece one score at least what is
he doing against the Berlin and let us
check yeah with the g3 and then the
capture that's really really yeah and
unexcited uh let's say but not bad of
course it's not a bad way to play for
white it just feels a little bit little
bit boring but ok I have played the
Berlin in the first place um yeah how
would you play that 97 maybe yeah i'm
not a huge expert or let's say any sort
of expert in the in the Berlin I just
wanted to do something else that's not
so man f6 not sure that he might have 93
to f5 there or this one I was a little
bit concerned about that ok well that's
that's a very simple way to play it
maybe not a bad way 95 95 I can also
just take a fire is it looky 196 not
good probably not good
okay yeah but this is definitely a
little bit better for wide my plan is
your paw I want to go here cover g6 now
i need to get my things developed here
ruki a drupe d8 it's not that bad I mean
I'm not very thrilled about this
position but it shouldn't be that bad
really if I go here I here has prepared
night at five of course should have
thought about it a moment moment longer
but maybe it's not that terrible yeah
yeah yeah okay well Quinn d5 yeah the
queen is an annoyance their rookie six
maybe yeah i was thinking that i can go
here and possibly night to h6
g4 I wanted to go age 5 i'm not sure
about it not not so great maybe yes g5
yes but okay it's not not much of a
choice here I g5 was interesting after
the capture yes Bishop g7 this is earth
should be okay right isn't this okay for
black yeah i'm going to take here and if
he takes here I go g64 to wait wait wait
wait just just one moment here rook is 6
first maybe
yeah Ruby 64 still get one roof traded
now with this one threatening King f7
now King f7 as a threat yes to play at
seven himself otherwise i go to f7 and i
just have to know what is allowing that
and now I'm just better here I think
with a good coordination and this point
is a weakness and they have six pawn
let's see how to do it may be here rook
age form look f1 that's 93 so I don't
really see a good move now for him King
f3 route h2s not so bright ok this one
and I can just take a six now if I want
he activates this rook
I'm not sure about it
I wonder if there's something better I
can always repeat here yeah you know
Bishop c3 now is the only move I think I
think what about now that's also not
great rupee aid I don't have much time
this is my problem man come on it's just
a pawn really let's take it and see what
what I can can accomplish em this was a
stupid move right it doesn't do anything
that we can do three a little bit but
still this is check and check maybe this
is a an idea now get and not really yeah
it was a was probably a stupid to try
for me it stupid try to again ok at
least I have King d5 to you for now as
an active idea I'm morning let's let's
do it
and night h 4f three years also also on
laughs it's not easy for white this sum
is a good attacking the checking force
here
kingi form King bee three and this
Knight to f3 idea Wow interesting okay I
don't cannot really calculate this this
is the sharpest try really going going
for the attack
I can take it right I know I have made
this is the problem he does not have a
check and that play king of rookie to
made I don't even need to stop the porn
white resigns yeah I was a tricky tricky
business I was certainly in big troll or
I don't know how big it was but it was
trouble I think he he made a mistake
here here he just has to play g5 yeah
the computer gives it as a winner yes I
have no move yeah if i take he's going
to take here jack and wins so this just
wins and after age three i think the the
worst is certainly over here Bishop f6
is still quite good check
yeah and this is running yeah i was i
was really in big trouble and this is
this is completely turning the tables
Bishop f6 again was possible here oh
yeah I could have played King f7 first
it's this much better of course and just
take the pawn that it was stupid that
was stupid really oh okay I wasn't
really sure what to do and then I went
for this check and then change here and
okay the computer gives me a win here
almost it's funny I wasn't sure it
looked dangerous but yeah it's it's that
this is really tough yeah after keenya
for I'm definitely winning yeah there
were many possibilities for both sides a
difficult difficult to say but glad to
have won this thanks for watching